and many of these new cases come from
the omicron variant new research on
nearly 80 000 omicron cases in south
africa finds the variant causes less
severe illness especially in vaccinated
adults deborah patta is tracking this
latest surge in south africa where
children under 12 are still not eligible
for vaccines
the lights are on and schools are out
it's south africa's summer holiday when
children should be thinking about
carefree days ahead
but the rise of covert cases amongst
kids in south african hospitals is a
worrying trend doctors on the front line
put it down to high community
transmission the infections are mostly
incidental says pediatrician dr gary
rubinson we're seeing children who being
admitted for elective surgical
procedures who's testing positive we've
seen children who have fractures and
other traumas are
completely unrelated to curvature
testing positive
vaccinologist professor shabir mahdi
stresses omicron is not targeting
children in a more severe way certainly
not so because it is more infectious and
more transmissible you might expect a
slight increase
in children that develop covert 19.
earlier this year the deadly delta third
wave overwhelmed south africa's
hospitals but the devastation then
might be a silver lining now high levels
of naturally induced immunity from
previous infections experts say could be
why omicron is so far less severe for
this particular wave i think we would be
in a much better space and we will
experience much fewer hospitalizations
as well as deaths from covert 19
compared with what we had experienced in
any of the previous three waves this
cautious optimism that covered won't
ruin another holiday this year for cbs
morning's debra patter johannesburg
you're right deborah it's ruined a lot
of holidays we are tired but we must
remain vigilant thank you